jack prescott continuing to get plenty
of support from anyone and everyone the
neighbors
putting the sign in the yard for dak
prescott who had a surgery and his home
and uh now the recovery process begins
but regardless how it plays out steven
jones cowboys co among other titles
appearing yesterday on 105 3 the fan
chris uh made it clear
that dak prescott is a big part of the
team's future here's steven jones
that conversation with him what was that
conversation like you know how much our
prayers are with him
how much we believe in him how much
we're going to miss him but at the same
time though she's going to come back
better stronger
better than ever dark face of our
franchise
to happen and know that he'll overcome
nothing you'll overcome this
driven special name
you know it's funny there's always a
a a balancing you go through when you
get a guest on a show and the radio and
the phone connection isn't good like at
what point do you say uh we'll call you
back or that's enough but when it's
stephen jones you just deal with it if
you're 105.3 the fan right especially on
a topic like that to hear what he has to
say it's the first time a cowboys
official addressing
the future and when you say face the
franchise you imply
he's going to continue to be with the
franchise and do what they have to do to
keep him around chris yeah i know i'm
that's where i'm i'm very interested to
see where it goes i mean yes doc
prescott is really awesome quarterback
there's no doubt about it you know the
talent is there yeah do i look at him
and go
okay he's one of the five most talented
guys in the game no i don't but i think
you and i agrees that next group down
there
uh certainly and then like we've heard
rodney on the clip before he brings so
many things to the to the table that you
know
that translate on the field but people
won't give him credit for as far as his
leadership and what he does there the
kind of human being he is everything
like that yeah that affects with how his
teammates look at him in the huddle how
they play for him all those type of
things to the the the big thing we're
just in unprecedented waters here that's
where i'm just like
i don't know where this goes i mean i
know you hear the the reports right
they're saying four to six months right
as far as the injury
and closer to six i would think that's
what i was gonna say i would think so in
my history of being around athletes who
have had these similar injuries yes it's
more of the six to seven to eight month
type of thing and then even when you get
back out there
you're not really yourself you know and
that's to me gonna be the big question
too and i guess that's the big question
is how do they balance this you know do
you just pay him a flat contract and pay
him like he's one of the two or three
best quarterbacks in football and pay
him big money and just go on with it i
do you put some sort of stipulation in
the contract mike i don't know i'm just
i'm very intrigued by the conversation
itself
let's remember yeah the options yeah
that's right
when and here here's the reality
the window opens on signing dak to a
multi-year deal as soon as the regular
season ends
there's no prohibition
on
the cowboys and dak prescott's agent
getting together and laying the
foundation yeah and working out a
contract that would be signed
immediately after the regular season
ends nothing prevents them from doing it
in the cba
the circumstances may make it something
where you want to take a wait and see
but you could start talking about any
and all possibilities for a long-term
deal right now
they're going to have until the window
closes for the application the franchise
tag or the transition tag both are going
to cost the same by rule 20 raise for
dak prescott 31.4 becomes 37.68 even if
the salary cap drops to 175.
and chris
look on one hand
dak prescott's reaction to this injury
could be to say
i was wrong to not take the security
that comes with a long-term deal i was
wrong to not take the nine figure injury
guarantee
i should have done it i wish i had or
or
he could say
hey
you forced me to go year to year because
you didn't properly value me you didn't
give me the security that i wanted
and
i'm not gonna agree to and ah shucks you
got a bad leg type of a deal some sort
of a band-aid one-year thing to see what
you have or something with a big option
bonus payment in the second year like
what drew brees signed when he joined
the saints in 2006 because he had the
bad shoulder it was one year and then it
was up to the saints to unlock the rest
of the deal no he could say
look
you you either apply the franchise tag
at 37.68
or you let me become a free agent and
we'll let the market decide what i'm
worth i mean that's what i've been
saying for the last year and a half
that's one of the reasons why i hate the
franchise tag even though it's not going
away it gives the team a way to prevent
the market from determining a player's
worth so we're stuck having all these
theoretical hypothetical conversations
about what a player is worth we never
get a chance to find out there's one way
to find out what he's worth put him on
the market and that may be what daca and
you know what based upon the way he has
stared down the cowboys and their
efforts to ah shucks him into doing a
team-friendly deal in the past
i think he's gonna say i fully intend to
be healthy i fully intend to be play i
typically be playing i fully intend to
be the guy that i've always been
so you either apply the franchise tag or
we're gonna let the market decide what
i'm worth period i i i i hear what
you're saying i i would just say that if
i were dak prescott
uh or if i was a friend of his and he
called me
and asked me for my advice i i would go
with you know the first thing you said
where it would just
you know
go go with a big time deal maybe you're
not the highest paid guy in football or
whatever that is
and just be happy that you got the
guarantee the security you're the cowboy
the cowboy i mean you're the quarterback
of the cowboys and all these special
things
and you know kind of like what i said
back in in march you know when we were
talking about the contract situation you
know at the end of the day and i know
this is easy for me to say sitting here
as a talking head on tv but i don't
think whether he's got 150 million in
the bank or 142 million in the bank is
going to make a difference that's what
i've always kind of argued and you know
the last thing i'll say at least as far
as this mike is i mean if he is to hit
the open market right do you think
anybody's going to give him like big
time money and you're or it'd be that
type of deal i guess you're right with
like a drew brees type of thing maybe i
i just i'm interested to where that goes
it doesn't have to be big time money
just has to be more than what the
cowboys are offering that's the key it
doesn't have to be 40 million a year and
you know the cam newton
experience where he languishes on the
market
the patriots get him and he ends up
being great that could cause one of
those owners out there to say go get go
get this guy sure he may not be healthy
now
but look at what he's going to be when
he is healthy and and i was looking
through the standings
yesterday the jets why would they not
potentially be interested in dak
prescott depending upon what's going on
in the organization after this season
the jaguars may be looking for a new
everything after this year because one
in four isn't going to get it done the
colts they have a one-year deal with
phillip rivers who would you rather have
chris dak prescott or philip rivers next
well that's not even close yeah stack
prescott okay right the broncos drew
lock hey if drew lock can't stay on the
field he can't be the quarterback you
and i both think he can be great but if
you can't stay healthy you can't play
and i understand that they'd be trading
in drew locke for dak prescott coming
off of a serious injury but other than
that one freak injury the guy hadn't
missed a game his entire career and i
haven't even gotten to the nfc
let's dispense with the obvious
candidates like the 49ers
if they move on from jimmy garoppolo
wouldn't your guy kyle be interested in
a guy like dax i would think so i mean i
don't know why why anybody wouldn't be
interested in dak if you felt like he
was available right go ahead the the the
the saints
dak prescott taysom hill if drew brees
retires maybe sean payton looks at dak
prescott and says man what i could do
with him if i had him in my offense and
and i'm i'm fine i'm going to gloss over
the nfc north although the lions could
be in play or the bears
uh
maybe even the vikings if they trade
kirk cousins to your guy in san
francisco which i think is entirely
possible after the way jimmy garoppolo's
played this year but let's just stay in
the division
i mean wouldn't you love
if you're a team that plays the cowboys
twice a year to take dak prescott away
from the cowboys if they blow this i
mean we don't know what's going to
happen with daniel jones after this
season what about a jason garrett dak
prescott reunion with the giants what
about that wouldn't that be awesome
right if that happened washington don't
know what the hell they're doing at
quarterback the eagles are starting to
have doubts about carson wentz uh and
all that
that that is what pushes this toward
the cowboys not want to take that chance
and if they can't work out a deal with
dak
do you pull the trigger on 37.68 million
when you're not sure the guy is going to
be ready to go next year that's going to
be the question that and it's going to
be one of the biggest business questions
the cowboys have ever had to resolve in
the history of the franchise because
they're kind of in a weird spot i mean
they really are i mean even on like uh
i feel like a little bit of a humanity
level here now they are too right i mean
at least a little bit as far as okay
let's go back to the contract talks and
the negotiations and all that
i mean one you're right
dak prescott's going to be able to talk
or his agent they're going to talk to
the cowboys and go well i'm in this
predicament because of you guys you
wouldn't pony up the right amount of
money the first time he'll certainly be
able to say that but now the
circumstances have changed and
will dallas
still make a big market you know
marketplace type offer to him uh with
this injury looming right now because if
they don't or they kind of lowball him
or do something like that it's going to
look insensitive too so
i i just i'm interested to see if they
do talk about long-term contracts will
that offer stay the same as it was last
year where they just didn't like it and
supposedly there was a disagreement on
the you know the fourth or fifth year of
the contract whatever that is
um
or or does dak ask for a little bit more
money from the last year's negotiation
just saying hey it's the next year money
goes up there's just so many different
scenarios here and i think you know the
cowboys are in a tough spot and like you
said deck prescott i think is just going
to have to make a decision
on which way he wants to go with this
does he want to play hardball does he
want to just get the security of a
long-term contract and have to deal with
it and think about it anymore because i
am one that thinks some of that emotions
pouring out we saw on sunday is all of
that like i can't play with my team like
all the things you said and rodney said
before this but also like damn did i
mess up you know a chance of getting a
huge payday as well uh and there is
something to that to where that's off
your brain and you don't have to worry
about that anymore as well
i want what's best for dak yeah i want
all players to get every last penny that
they can and could get because they're
the ones out there taking that risk of a
serious injury on any given play i was
watching that game last night too i mean
you're now i'm watching for the pileups
and to see if someone else suffers a
serious leg injury like that once that's
in your brain
it's hard to get rid of it imagine how
hard it's going to be for dak to ever
get rid of that experience and he needs
to get what he deserves and his leverage
is
you pay me 3768 or we find out who else
out there may be interested
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports